salut tout le monde l'inde il vous est
demandé sur facebook et sur twitter ce
que vous voulez que je vous raconte
aujourd'hui en ce jeudi le fameux jeudi
de jeudi ce que je veux mais je dis
surtout ce que vous voulez pour ça j'ai
mis en place un petit sondage sur
twitter j'ai d'ailleurs fait une
connerie dans le sondage puisque je les
laissais valide que 24 heures au lieu de
les laisser valide quatre jours - c'est
la première fois que je faisais j'ai
découvert mais en 24 heures vous avez eu
le temps de répondre vous avez répondu
nombreux merci et vous m'avez réclamer
une trou story une histoire vraie un
petit peu comme la fois où j'avais
raconté comment j'avais retrouvé mon mac
qui avait perdu un match dans un train
et j'ai réussi à le retrouver je vous
raconte d'ailleurs l'histoire ici alors
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
comment je suis rentré sans payer à
disneyland paris c'est pas c'est pas une
histoire très longue mais c'est une
histoire vraie ça s'est passé en 2011
déjà il faut savoir qu'en 2011 j'avais
un pass annuel pour aller à disney on
m'avait offert un pass annuel pour mon
anniversaire et donc je pouvais rentrer
à disney quand je veux rejoindre
quelqu'un à disney c'est à dire que je
pars de chez moi pour aller à pied
jusqu'au métro je prends le métro pour
aller jusqu'aux et where je prends le
rer pour aller jusqu à disneyland et
j'arrive à disney je me dirige vers la
grande entrée qui lie à la très grande
entrée pour aller passer mon badge dans
le tourniquet et je m'aperçois que j'ai
pas mon badge est là c'est assez
inconfortable parce que j'ai pas mon bac
j'ai des gens qui m'attendent dans le
parc ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que
je vais pas faire l'aller-retour jusqu'à
chez moi pour aller chercher le badge et
je n'ai pas non plus de quoi me payer un
billet d'entrée puisque puisque autour
du badge j'avais rangé mon portefeuille
en clair je suis parti les poches vides
là je me suis dit c'est impossible de
rentrer à disney sans payer mais bon va
falloir quand même tenté un coup au
niveau de la grande entrée linga tout
tout tout tout les caisses c'est
l'entrée principale je me suis ici c'est
mort je vois rien négocier même si je
vais à l'espèce d'accueil qui attendront
l'a jamais ils voudront parlait donc
j'ai cherché une autre entrée je suis
allé quand on est face à disney sur la
droite
là où il ya je crois la bagagerie voilà
c'était au niveau de la bagagerie et 5
de ce côté là le matin il y avait
personne
je m'approche de l'accueil de la
bagagerie qui est aussi un accueil
secondaire dans l'entré disney et
j'explique en fait que j'ai pas ma carte
j'ai pas mon passes mais j'espère
qu'avec mon nom ils vont pouvoir me
retrouver même si je vous le rappelle je
ne peux pas justifier de mon identité
puisque je n'ai pas de portefeuille
alors là c'est assez drôle et c'est une
jeune fille qui m'expliquait lequel
qu'elle peut rien faire en fait même
avec le nom même si j'avais ma carte
d'identité de tenir à pourrais pas me
faire rentrer si la balle passe
la règle est stricte personne ne rentre
sans sont pas sous tend un billet est à
partir de ce moment là je me suis dit je
vais toujours acquiescé je vais jamais
dans le négatif
jamais déçu mais je vais être dans la
tempe je m'explique je dis ah ok ok je
comprends tout à fait est-ce que du coup
je peux voir un responsable elle hésite
je répète ma phrase je change pas un mot
je fais non mais vraiment je comprends
mais ce que je peux voir quand même un
responsable sont responsables arrivent
sur la petite porte une vraie porte
physique qui a sur le côté et dès qu'il
a ouvert la porte j'ai fait la technique
du commercial je suis rentré direct pour
pas qu'ils puissent surtout pas
refermées et j'avançais un petit peu
sans rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle sa
bulle d'intimité mais je m'avançais pour
qu'ils reculent un petit peu je rentre
vraiment dans le couloir j'explique
toute la problématique j'en passe je les
oubliés chez moi j'étais souriant en
gardant la même ligne de conduite
toujours dire oui mais attendre c'est à
dire que je vais explique le problème et
faire baver mais alors là nous s'en
passe on peut pas vous faire entrer je
fais d'accord ok ça j'ai compris et
essayer c'est très plaisant pétant du
coup on fait comment et j'attends en
place ont peut-être un petit peu pour un
blaireau quand je repense nos mecs
murray explique phénomène en fait même
avec votre nom dans le fichier même si
on pouvez vous retrouver on pourrai pas
vous faire rentrer on n'a aucun moyen
même physiquement que même vous voulez
de vous faire entrer jaoui oui d'accord
ok je comprends et c'est embêtant du
coup on fait comment et à chaque fin de
phrase répétée le on fait comment sans
agressivité toujours avec calme et
surtout en lui barrant le passage c'est
à dire que si lui voulait passer où je
me pousse il était obligé de monter d'un
ton dans la conversation alors que
jusqu'à maintenant j'avais été le mec le
plus sympathique du monde juste jubal
ray la route ils pouvaient plus sortir
il pouvait plus faire demi tour parce
que je bloquais aussi l'accès au bureau
et je le laissais répéter ces phrases en
disant oui je comprends et du coup on
fait comment je pense de mémoire que ça
a bien duré 5 6 minutes
ça paraît pas l'on grandit 5 6 minutes
mais c'est assez long à vivre dans ce
genre de situation jusqu'au moment
magique offert et on veut dire prendre
puisqu'au moment magique aux effets ont
écouté je vous fais rentrer par contre
vous pourrez pas ressortir aux rentrées
comme vous voulez et c'est la première
et la dernière fois que ça arrivera quoi
donc là on était passé du c'est
impossible quand bien même on le
voudrait
ah je vais vous faire rentrer autant
vous dire qu'à ce moment là je suis
restée très modeste très humble pas fait
exploser ma joie parce que là ça
contrecarrer tout ce que j'ai fait au
préalable en gardant vraiment la même
base d'un zona sur la même base
d'énergie alors j'avais envie de faire
c'est bon ils avaient une carte blanche
il m'a fait passer avec cette espèce de
carte blanche je suis rentré dans le
parc
j'ai profité du parc toute la journée je
suis donc rentré dans disney sans billet
sans rien du tout sans invitation sans
que dalle je suis rentré dans le parc 1
le grand parc
alors après je me dis c'était pas du vol
puisque j'avais le pas samuel chez moi à
quoi sauf que je l'avais pas avec moi
évidemment je vous déconseille d'éviter
de faire les mêmes choses comme ça qu'il
ya deux mille personnes de ma à disney
qui tente sachez même pas sûr que ça
pourrait se reproduire
moi j'étais un stress permanent durant
toute cette histoire je savais quelles
techniques utilisées pour pour accéder à
ça mais j'avais un vrai doute sur le
fait qu'il est vraiment le pouvoir de me
faire rentrer ou pas et j'avais une
crainte c'était qu'il appelle la
sécurité en fait quand j'ai bloqué le
passage mais c'était assez drôle de
tenter le coup
je regrette à l'époque de pas avoir eu
de caméras en 2011 pour filmer sa soeur
était assez marrant je pense ans comme
cache merci d'avoir écouté ce trou story
j'espère que ça vous a plu vous pouvez
d'ailleurs me le dire en laissant un
petit pouce en l'air ou 1 comme en bas
je les lis tous en ce moment je suis un
peu à la bourre pour répondre mais je
veux rattraper ce retard ça s'est
produit lundi prochain je vous
solliciterez encore de nouveau alors je
sais pas si ça va être sur twitter sur
facebook ou sur instagram en tout cas je
relaierai l'info sur les trois réseaux
il n'était pas à chaque fois c'est
fabien olicard et vous déciderez encore
de quelque chose pour la vidéo de jeudi
n'oubliez pas avant de partir de vous
abonner à la chaîne parce que le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour tous les
jours pendant un an alors rendez vous
demain 17h pour le prochain mortal blogs
chats